Joining us now US Surgeon
General Dr. Jerome Adams Dr.
Adams Thanks for being here.
Thank you for having me Bret
and thank you to the American
people who kept it small
and smart this Thanksgiving
millions of people did the right
thing.
And for those who did travel
and those who did attend large
gatherings we want you to know
it's not too late to take
measures to slow the spread
of this virus you can still
isolate you can still get tested
in 3 to five days you can still
take measures that have been
proven to help us prevent cases,
hospitalizations, and deaths
while speaking of that new cases
of Friday surpassed 205,000
and that was breaking a record
set the week before
hospitalizations were at record
levels in a number of states,
including Oregon Washington
Indiana and Pennsylvania so I
guess the question is is this
what a dark winter looks like
or do you forecast that this is
going to get worse in coming
weeks.
Well I want to be straight with
the American people it's going
to get worse over the next
several weeks.
But the actions that we take
in the next several days will
determine how bad it is
or whether or not we continue
to flatten our curve in right
before Thanksgiving we actually
saw cases start to plateau
and many states that have been
aggressively mitigating and as I
mentioned there are steps you
can take right now.
But I also want people to know
there's hope we are mere weeks
away from starting to vaccinate
the vulnerable and we can
significantly protect people who
are at risk for this virus.
So hang on just a little bit
longer I understand that
the science out there has never
been stronger to support
the wearing of masks you
shouldn't have to have a mandate
to do the right thing to protect
your neighbor to keep schools
open make sure you're watching
your distance and make sure,
again, if you've been
in a gathering of more than 10
people without your mask on over
the last several days please get
tested in the next three to five
days I want to talk about
the vaccines the therapeutics
in just a second.
But what do you think looking
back now was the biggest mistake
the administration health
experts made since this pandemic
started well that is a great
question.
And there are many different
things that we could have done
differently this virus has been
challenging I wish that that
again this hadn't been
superimposed on top
of an election I wish that
we'd been able to come together
as a nation and really talk
about the science instead
of the politics
and that's on all sides
that's all around but what I
want people to know is moving
forward again, the science
it's never been stronger
in terms of what we can do
simple powerful measures
I'm wearing a mask
as an instrument of freedom.
It actually will let my kids go
to school it will protect
my mother and you and I talked
about this before the interview
my mother's in the hospital
right now I want people
to understand that if cases
and hospitalizations continue
to go up not only will it hurt
our ability to care for COVID
patients.
But if someone's having a baby
they may not be able to get
a bed if someone is having
a heart attack or a potential
stroke like my mother they may
not be able to get a bed
your actions have consequences
and if you do the right thing,
then it will bridges
to a vaccine so hopeful
so hopeful that we can get
to that vaccine with a few lives
lost as possible Yeah you
tweeted out last week that
the CDC and others now estimate
that 50% or even more
of the infections that are
around the country are
transmitted from people who are
not exhibiting symptoms
obviously that was not what was
believed that the beginning
of this pandemic.
Absolutely and I'm so glad you
brought that up because again
mask had become politicized
but I want people to understand
that in the beginning we did not
think based on our experience
with any other respiratory virus
that we would have this high
degree of asymptomatic spread
that means people spreading it
who look fine who feel fine who
don't have a fever,
we now know that over 50%
of people according to the CDC
who are spreading this virus
in the community look and feel
fine that's why we want you
to know that household
gatherings they've been super
spreader events they've been
opportunities that have led led
to viral spread and it's why we
need everyone to continue to be
cautious that's why we need you
to think about what you did over
the holidays if you traveled
if you were in a gathering with
a mask off with people outside
of your household you can take
steps now to prevent you being
an asymptomatic spreader
and turning into community
spread still a chance for us
to flatten this curve get
to a vaccine wouldn't you say
that testing was one
of the mistakes at the beginning
and even now you do have testing
all over the country.
But it's sometimes tough.
I talked to many family members
who were trying to get the fast
test in order to go feel safe
at a Thanksgiving dinner and it
was 3 to five hours wait it was
maybe you didn't get the fast
test it was two three days
hasn't that been a vulnerability
in how we as a country have
dealt with this well I certainly
believe testing has been
a challenge but I want people
to know that we are now over 160
million test we've tested more
than anyone else in the world I
don't want to say that
that's the reason the Pats
on the back, but I want people
to testing is available.
And one of the things
we're trying to help people
understand particularly public
health officials is that you can
use these new antigen test which
return term results in 15,
20 minutes they are just
as effective at practically
understanding who can spread
the virus as the PCR test
and so we want them
to aggressively use these tests
so that people can get a quick
answer and they know whether
or not to isolate
or to quarantine are you talking
about the vaccines tell people
where the optimism the reality
is as far as timing and when
the average American could get
a vaccine I personally am
incredibly optimistic December
10th is when Pfizer will be
submitting its EUA
that's the plan December 18 is
when my journey is scheduled
to submit its EUA
that's the plan from Moderna
and within 24 to 48 hours after
submitting their EUA
we from a federal perspective
have promised and it set
everything up so that we can
quickly review those the ways.
And hopefully start sending out
vaccines, again within 24 to 48
hours.
Our plan is to start
by protecting the vulnerable
older people,
particularly in Long term care
facilities we want to immunize
for impact with the recognition
that we'll have 40 million doses
of vaccine by the end of this
year but that won't be enough
for the whole country
if you're part of the public I
want you to understand
it'll probably be in the first
quarter beginning of second
quarter next year before you can
get a vaccine but you can go
to coronavirus Prevention
Network sign up for a study
and you could be can get
a vaccine in just a few days
to weeks if you sign up
for a study and understand that
again our strategy that
we're telling governors
and states is to think about the
vulnerable if we protect them
then we can slow the spread
of this disease and lower loss
of life until everyone can get
a vaccine again into first
quarter into the second quarter
next year and if the FDA moves
forward with authorization
people should be comfortable
that it's safe well let me be
clear.
I have been working with all
of these companies I've been
following along closely
I'm a doctor and when they tell
me I can get a vaccine I will be
first in line to get a vaccine
because that's how safe.
I think this vaccine will be I
want people to understand safety
has not been compromised
efficacy has not been
compromised what we've done is
is really thrown a lot of money
at this problem to lower
the risk for companies
and we've moved them
to the front of the line
in terms of evaluation
so their applications are
sitting on a desk we decrease
the amount of time that is
wasted in the process without
compromising safety or review
or efficacy and at 90% to 95%
safe 90 90% to 95% efficacy what
I would hate is if we had
a vaccine, that could in this
pandemic and people actually
didn't get it wouldn't in this
pandemic.
This vaccine will have more
people who who who've been
tested than any other vaccine
in history at the point
of authorization about 5,000
people are normally enrolled
in vaccine trials these trials
have 30 to 60,000 people.
So I feel confident it's safe I
will get a vaccine when they
tell me I can get a vaccine Dr.
Adams I want to leave with this
this was an image that went
viral in recent days
and it's very powerful
it's an ICU doctor embracing
a COVID 19 patients
on Thanksgiving day this was
from Houston Dr. Joseph veron
a doctor on his 250 second
straight day of work at United
Memorial Medical Center
in Houston and you can see
it's a powerful image there are
thousands of doctors and nurses
out there like Dr. veron
on the frontlines in this
pandemic and they
as you've talked about are
really the true heroes
throughout all this time exactly
and I want to thank Dr.
Christine Kaminski s who is
actually the resident physician
who's taking care of my mother
in the hospital right now she
called me right before I went
on the air to tell me that
my mother was doing OK doctors
and nurses they need you
the American people to take
small simple measures that will
protect them and get us
to a vaccine.
And I also know you've got
the New Jersey Governor coming
on please tell him I said thank
you his wife and I've been
working on maternal health.
Another thing that we've seen
people really not pay attention
to during this pandemic 700
women died during the time
of child around the time
of childbirth every year 2/3 are
preventable and we'll be having
a call to action coming out
in the next few days so remember
this pandemic is affecting us
in many different ways
but our frontline workers really
need us to do our part well Dr.
Adams we appreciate your time.
Thank you for that time during
these busy days and best of luck
with your family.
Thank you.